what's going on everybody today we got
some pretty big news on phase four this
is really exciting because it doesn't
seem like there's going to be any sort
of break between Avengers 4 and the next
phase quick reminder about the giveaway
I'm doing i'm giving away a few copies
of Avengers infinity war on blu-ray all
you have to do to enter the giveaway is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and leave a comment below so the huge
news is that it looks like Marvel
Studios is looking to move forward on
phase 4 in June of 2019 this is only a
couple of months after the release of
Avengers 4 so it really does seem like
there's not going to be very much of a
gap between Avengers 4 and the next
phase so what is going to start off
phase 4 originally it was supposed to be
guardians of the galaxy guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 was supposed to begin
shooting early 2019 but it seems like
that's been put on hold due to the
firing of James Gunn so until they can
get a new director on it it seems like
that's not going to be happening however
we were just teased about Doctor Strange
2 and if you haven't seen my video on
that you can check it out in the link
above scott derrickson who directed the
first Doctor Strange movie recently
posted on Instagram a photo of dr.
strange from the comics and said see you
in September so I'm not sure if this is
enough time from September to June for
them to have everything really down pat
for Doctor Strange too for them to start
filming so this might not be what's
going to pick off phase 4 but it's
definitely a possibility they may
already be talking about it it may
already be in the works but maybe
September there will be some sort of
official early stating that Doctor
Strange 2 is coming I'm not sure but I
do however think there is one movie that
will probably kick off phase 4 and that
is the Eternals this has already been
rumored for a pretty long time now and
one thing it does do is fit into the
whole cosmic future
of the MCU and it could also fit into
Avengers 4 somehow you could certainly
introduce them in the movie whether or
not they play a huge part whether it's
an opposed credit scene you could
definitely introduce them and not to
mention the movie is currently being
written by Matthew and Ryan Firpo so if
you'd asked me I would certainly say
that this is going to be the movie to
kick off phase 4 especially with the
direct link to Thanos Thanos says mother
father and brother are all Eternals and
not to mention Red Skull actually
mentions Anna's father a Lars in
Infinity Ward so I think this movie the
Eternals would be the most likely option
but whatever the movie to kick off phase
4 is it's just awesome that it's going
to start in June of 2019 not too far
from now what do you all think about
this news and what do you think the best
movie to kick off phase 4 of the MCU is
leave your thoughts in the comments
below and again a reminder about the
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and leave a comment below thank you so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]